Y a des mecs, ils arrivent à avoir une attitude
de beau gosse, en toutes circonstances,
ce qui me rend pas
spécialement jaloux. Faux !
Le beau gosse,
c'est un leader.
S'il se lève pour partir,
tout le monde le suit.
Bon, allez, on y va, les gars ?
Genre, c'est lui qui décide.
Alors que moi, quand
j'ai envie de partir,
Les gars, allez !
Le beau gosse, quand il se déshabille
pour faire l'amour, il est sauvage.
Excuse-moi,
j'avais chaud.
Ça veut dire que le mec, à chaque fois
qu'il se déshabille, il détruit une chemise.
Moi, je préfère ma méthode à moi.
J'ai pas sué dedans, donc
je vais la remettre demain.
Le beau gosse,
quand il aborde une fille,
même s'il utilise la phrase d'accroche
la plus banale du monde, ça fonctionne !
Je peux te payer un verre ?
Moi, les seules fois où j'ai essayé
d'aborder une meuf avec ce genre de phrase,
j'avais juste l'impression
d'être un gros pervers !
Tu veux boire
de l'alcool avec moi ?
Allez, bois-en plein, plein si tu veux.
Moi, j'ai pas de meuf,
mais j'en veux bien une, hein.
Allez, viens boire,
viens boire avec moi !
Le beau gosse, quand il est au restaurant
et qu'il choisit un vin, il s'y connaît.
Mmh, je vais prendre
un Saint Émilion, s'il vous plaît, 96.
Moi, le vin,
je choisis au hasard.
Mais si le serveur me fait goûter
en ouvrant la bouteille,
je fais quand même genre
de m'y connaître un petit peu.
Pas mal, c'est bien ça !
Même si c'est pas vrai.
Ah, excusez-moi, en fait, c'est du
sans plomb 95, je crois que je me suis trompé.
Ah ! Ah, ouais, ouais,
je me disais bien.
Ça, c'est pas une bonne année,
ça. 95, ouais.
D'ailleurs, le beau gosse, quand
il boit du vin rouge, il est classe.
Moi, quand je bois du vin rouge,
ça fait cet effet-là :
Les beaux gosses, quand ils arrivent
en boîte, ils connaissent le videur.
Même pas ils se posent la question
de savoir s'ils vont rentrer dans la boîte.
Ça va Queen ?
>> Ça va, cool, et toi ?
On est 45.
>> Y a des meufs ?
Ah non, aucune !
>> Bon, allez-y, les gars !
On se fait une choucroute,
ce weekend, hein ?
Quand tu veux.
>> À plus tard !
Moi, j'aimerai trop
être pote avec un videur.
Alors, à chaque fois, quand je passe devant,
je fais genre d'être cool.
Salut, ça va ?
Ah !
Je suis désolé,
ça va pas être possible, ce soir.
Ah ! OK. Bon,
c'est pas grave.
T'inquiète, mon pote !
À plus tard !
Le beau gosse, quand il se promène
dans la rue avec sa copine,
et que des mecs l'embrouillent,
il réagit comme ça :
Ah comment t'es bonne, toi !
T'inquiète, la fraîcheur ! Viens ici, eh viens !
Attends, attends, reste là !
Oh, oh, les mecs, comment
vous parlez à ma copine là ?
C'est quoi ces manières ? Hein ?
Vous vous calmez, OK ?
Désolé, monsieur !
>> Ouais, j'aime mieux ça, hein !
Mon bonnet ?
>> Viens, ma chérie !
Il t'a pris ton bonnet !
>> Ouais, je lui ai donné !
Moi aussi, moi aussi, quand
ça m'arrive, je suis pareil. Trop !
Regarde pas,
ne regarde pas !
Réponds pas,
réponds pas !
Ne t'abaisse pas
à leur hauteur, s'il te plaît !
À trois on court. Trois !
>> Hé viens là, hé, vas-y, viens !
Le beau gosse,
dans une soirée, c'est le mec
qui te sort une guitare sèche
et qui te met une pure ambiance en une seconde.
Hé, ça va, c'est bon,
c'est juste une guitare, hein !
Ça va, moi aussi,
je sais jouer d'un instrument, OK !
C'était "Quand il pète,
il troue son slip".
Remix.
Le beau gosse, à la piscine,
tu le repères facilement.
C'est le seul mec qui rentre dans l'eau
en moins d'une demi-seconde,
et en général
comme ça :
Hé, les filles,
elle est bonne ou pas ?
Elle est super bonne ! Ha ha !
Vous venez ou pas ?
Moi, à la piscine, quand je rentre
dans l'eau, c'est plutôt comme ça :
Ah ! Elle est pas
chau-chaude, hein !
Je vais y aller doucement, parce que
j'ai mangé y a pas longtemps, là.
Donc il faut que je fasse
attention à l'hydrocution.
Un beau gosse,
ça sait réparer une voiture.
Je veux dire, les meufs, elles kiffent,
parce que c'est viril.
Essayez de démarrer, voir !
C'est ce que je pensais,
c'est les bougies qui étaient encrassées.
Je sais même pas faire
la première étape de la réparation.
C'est où le bouton
pour ouvrir le capot ?
C'est celui-là ?
Ah non, c'est pas ça,
c'est pas ça, attends !
Le beau gosse, même pour rentrer
dans sa voiture, il a du charisme.
C'est parti !
Moi, j'aimerais trop,
comme dans Starsky et Hutch,
rentrer dans une décapotable
sans ouvrir la portière.
Mais bon, il faut
une décapotable, quoi !
Moi, je suis moche, je suis pas
un beau gosse comme ça, je sais pas faire.
Mais je m'en fous, en fait.
Moi, j'ai d'autres talents.
C'est bon,
j'ai trouvé une solution !